it was a lot of emotions I felt like a
cat in heat you know I will never forget
this experience it feels like the end of
an era
yeah it does the fourth and final season
where do things pick back up after that
crazy cliffhanger few months after yeah
yeah cuz this is like the second
semester of smear a couple months later
so it's like time job yes yeah obviously
Jessica was kind of involved in Bryce's
death where does that story line go I
can't say break me please definitely
will see some pasta maker may not see
some repercussions or Consequences
definitely you'll see her battling with
like the internal turmoil of being
responsible for sure okay I'm sure he's
right she always it's like going through
stepping she's always going through
something you know so she'll yeah we're
just gonna internalize I'm just I'm
gonna see you're like happy sad
screaming you know the whole enchilada
yeah we also have to talk about Jessica
and Justin's relationship what are the
chances that their endgame does that
mean like are they gonna end up together
okay got it I've been seeing that a lot
that's the hope that's the hope okay
that there how do you say it that their
endgame there yeah and they are and
begin all right like one of you know
this area size
thanks I've been seeing it on the
internet they're like yeah that's
endgame I'm like I mean do you really
believe me yes of course I do
what type of obstacles do Jessica and
Justin go through in this final season
there's the new character in town so
we'll never know what's gonna happen
who knows Jessica thinks he's hot
Diego was like Diego who's that fresh
meat you know and you know just like
it's got a little flavor you turn 18 you
know you know Justin I think he's in a
place where he's watching Jessica make
her own decisions and he respects her
and so okay
I think Justin internalizes up mostly
his emotions towards it and he has a lot
of other focuses this season sobriety
sobriety is one of them and trying to to
stay on top of that yeah how's that
going for him yes well see Zach you were
also partially to blame yeah yeah I was
I was a part of that whole ordeal what I
did love about last season is the way
that the whole Tyler situation
he came forward as a victim of sexual
assault any poignant moments that we can
expect in this final-season yeah I think
so absolutely they're the all the
characters come they you see them mature
and they come to these you know
realizations and I think that naturally
would come with very powerful powerful
moments let's talk about the final days
on set then was it emotional what was
going through your guys's head yeah it
was a lot of emotions I felt like a cat
in heat you know like not horny but just
drama for you yeah also like a you guys
kind of changed the way that the show
went and there was a murder mystery is
there a murder mystery this time around
is everyone and even the court yeah and
from so many angles you know am i safe
from like losing a friend or am i safe
happen to law am i safe from death am i
safe all these things I think it's just
going through a lot always expect that
kind of yeah anything shocking
season as you were going through the
scripts where you were like I can't
believe this is the turn that we're
taking oh yeah
mostly yeah yeah we were like what why
there's so much variety tone-wise yeah
story-wise it's I I think cuz I saw you
a few weeks ago I was just like this
season is not something we didn't expect
any of it yeah he's a lot of I mean when
we were going to the deep dark places it
was a lot of fun just really got to
stretch as actors I feel like
[Music]